حذر وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري من
مواصله اثيوبيا بناء وتعبئه سد النهضه من
دون اتفاق قانونيه ملزم مع دولتي المصب
السودان ومصر واكد شكري ان سد النهضه يمثل
قضيه محوريه ذات اولويه متقدمه لبلاده وان
له تبعات خطيره على انها القومي وكانت
تقارير اكدت في يناير الماضي استمرار
اثيوبيا في التجهيزات لبدء التعبئه
الرابعه للسد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الرسائل التي ارادت
القاهره توجيهها بتاكيد قلقها من مواصله
اثيوبيا مشروعه بناء وتشغيل سد النهضه من
دون اتفاق وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان تستقبل
اديس ابابا هذه الرسائل وما دلاله تجاهل
اثيوبيا الانزعاج المصري ومواصله
استعدادها للتعبئه الرابعه للسد وما
خيارات مصر لمواجهه ما تعتبرها مخاطر تهدد
انها القومي وما فرص التواصل الى حل يرضي
جميع اطراف ازمه سد النهضه وما هو الدور
الذي يمكن ان يلعبه الوسطاء الافارقه
والدوليون في وضع حد لهذه الازمه
[موسيقى]
على لسان وزير خارجيتها سامح شكري كشفت
القاهره عن عمق انزعاجها من المسار الذي
تاخذه ازمه سد النهضه بسبب ما سمته
استمرار الحكومه الاثيوبيه في بناء وتشغيل
السد من دون اتفاق قانونيا ملزما مع
السودان ومصر امر اعتبره شكر انتهاكا
لقواعد القانون الدولي واجبه التطبيق
ومخالفه لبيان مجلس الامن الدولي الرئاسي
الصادر في سبتمبر عمى 21
شكري الذي اكد ان قضيه سد النهضه محوريه
واولويه متقدمه بالنسبه لمصر وذا تبعات
خطيره على امنها القومي قال امام مجلس
الجامعه العربيه على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه
قال ان بلاده تعول على الدعم العربي في
قضيه سد النهضه وعلى حمل اثيوبيا على تخلي
عما سماها سياساتها الاحاديه غير
التعاونيه ودفعها للتحلي بالاراده
السياسيه اللازمه
بالحلول الوسطى
تقارير وصور بالاقمار الاصطناعيه اظهرت في
يناير الماضي مواصله اثيوبيا تجهيزاتها
لبدء التعبئه الرابعه لسد النهضه خلال
الصيف المقبل وكانت الحكومه الاثيوبيه
اعلنت الصيف الماضي اكتمال التعبئه
الثالثه لسد النهضه بما حجمه 22 مليار متر
مكعب من المياه عقب موسم التعبئه الثانيه
التي اكتملت في صيف عام 2021 بحجم ثلاثه
مليارات متر مكعب
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من القاهره
السفير حسين هريدي مساعد وزير الخارجيه
المصريه الاسبق ومن اديس ابابا كامل شمس
عضو البرلمان الاثيوبي مرحبا بكما سيد
هريدي ابدا معك ما الذي اراده السيد سامح
شكري من طرح هذا الملف امام
مجلس الجامعه العربيه على المستوى
الخارجيه هل هو استغلال للممبر فقط ام
اكثر من ذلك
مساء الخير يعني
حضرتك مش اول مره انه
مسؤولين رفيع مستوى في مصر
يتحدثون هذا الموضوع اللي بيمثل الاهميه
القصوى للش
عب في المنابر العربيه
والقرارات اذا عدنا للقرارات القيم
العربي
الدول العربيه على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه
او حتى على مستوى حضرتك المندوبين
الدائمين هنجد دائما ان في مسانده عربيه
وتدعو
الى التوصل الى اتفاق بين مصر والسودان
واثيوبيا حول تشغيل سد النهضه الاجتماع
اليوم كان منبر اخر تطرح فيه مصر رؤيتها
وكما ذكرتي حضرتك بتطلب تاييد
مسانده في الدول العربيه لموقف
ها الى التوصل لاتفاق بين الاطراف الثلاثه
بالنسبه لتشغيل سد النهضه في في المستقبل
نحن طبعا مصر شرحت موقفها في العديد من
المناسبات
ويعني مصر من الدول التي تعاني من الشح
المائي وبتعاني من التغيرات المناخيه وكما
تعلمين حضرتك والساده المشاهدين الكرام
يعني تقريبا 95% من احتياجات مصر المائيه
تاتي من نهر النيل وبالتالي
مصر
حريصه كل الحرص على انها تصل الى اتفاق
بالتراضي
وبالوسائل الدبلوماسيه مع اثيوبيا ومع
السودان يحقق مصالح الاطراف الثلاثه
كيف يمكن ان تستقبل اديس ابابا
هذه الرسائل التي وجهت من قبل مصر دوله
منزعجه من المسار الذي تاخذه ياخذه هذا
الملف هل يعني لها شيئا
مساء الخير لك مشاهدين الكرام ولضيفك
الكريم من القاهره ايضا
ويعني نحن نرد على هذا التصريح بالاستغراب
والاعجاب من حيث التوقيت ومن حيث الموقع
اولا هذا
التعبئه الرابعه لسه نحن يعني نقوم بتعبئه
الرابعه يعني لو وقت طويل وايضا هذا
الحديث اثير في جامعه الدول العربيه في
اجتماع وزراء الدوله الوزراء الخارجين
الدول العربيه لا علاقه يعني ما علاقه هذا
يعني المكان بما بما يعني يتعلق بسد
النهضه سد النهضه يعني قضيه افريقيه لو
كان هذا الاجتماع اجتماع افريقيه اجتماع
في دول فارقه وكذا صحيح نستطيع يعني هذا
المكان مكانه
ترد او الى يعني
تدخل العربيه
هي الدول ايضا افريقيا وهي معنيه
بالوصول الى اتفاق يعني بالتراضي كما ذكر
السيد هريدي يتفق عليه الطرفان في ملف مهم
لدوله محوريه منزعجه من الامر
نحن علاقتنا مع الدول العربيه علاقه وطيده
علاقه تاريخيه اصيله هناك دوله دول
العربيه يعني موجودين في افريقيا نعرف هذا
لكن في هذه الفتره في هذا الاجتماع ما
الذي يعني انا لا اعرف ما الذي دفع يعني
سامي شكري
لطرح هذا السؤال يعني منذ تسلمه وزاره
تولي الرئاسه هذه لماذا لان اثيوبيا دائما
تقول انما تقوم به من مر سد النهضه يعني
هو لمصلحتها ولمصلحه دول المصب نحن لا
نلحق او هل هناك اي تاكيد بالحاق الضرر من
يعني الاول والثاني والثالث يعني ما في اي
شيء محقق المياه لا زالت تجري ويتعلق
بالتغيرات المناخيه هذه قضيه دوليه هذه
يعني كوارث الطبيعيه والجفافه هذه موجوده
في كل العالم
اثيوبيا كما قال يعني
كما ان مصر يعني
95% لها 95 لها مصالح على النيل اثيوبيا
ايضا منبعها يعني 85% من اثيوبيا لابد من
ان تستفيد اثيوبيا تدعو دائما للحوار
لاعاده هذا الملف الى البيت الافريقي
والجلوس عليه بالتراضي والنقاش على
النقطه
الوسيط يعني الاكثر موثوقيه وربما
عملياتيا في امكانيه التوسط ولكن سيد
هريدي يعني سامح شكري اعتبر هذا الملف هو
خط امن قومي احمر معنيه مصر به بقوه في
هذه المرحله التي تشهد جمود على مستوى
التفاوض زائد ايضا استمراريه في العمل على
مست ويات التعبئه في السد ما الذي يمكن ان
تفعله مصر
ما الذي يمكن ان تفعله مصر
يعني حضرتك
[تصفيق]
احنا في الدبلوماسيه المصريه الدبلوماسيه
ديناميكيه
وفي كل المنابر
مصر بتطرح رؤاها للعديد من القضايا سواء
قضايا داخليه لها ابعاد دوليه او ابعاد
افريقيه او عربيه او قضايا اخرى تهم
المجتمع الدولي دوما حق من كل دوله ذات
اسياد واثاره هذا الموضوع امام الدول
العربيه لا ينبغي ان تنظر اليه اثيوبيا
انه موقف عدائي او دوت او او دي محاوله
مصريه لاستعداد
الدول العربيه ضد اثيوبيا نحن نرحب
بالعلاقات العربيه الاثيوبيه لانها في
النهايه علاقات بتصب لصالح كافه الدول
العربيه بما في ذلك مصر
عندما نطرح هذا امام امام تطرح مصر امام
هذا القضيه المصريه لها القضيه الوجوديه
انا لن اقول مصريه
قضيه وجوديه لانه حضرتك كما قيل وكما يقال
مصر هي عده النيل يعني لا نستطيع ان نفصل
مصر عن النيل تاريخا وجغرافيا وحياه وتقدم
وتنميه وبالتالي نحن
بنحاول نوظف كل
علاقتنا العربيه علاقتنا الافريقيه
علاقتنا الدوليه لكي
نمهد الطريق حضرتك الاستئناف المفاوضات
بين مصر واثيوبيا والسودان بلغه التوصل
للارتفاع نحن يعني احنا مش بنشكك فيه
نوايا اثيوبيا لا نشكك اطلاقا
ونقدر الكلام اللي بيتقال سواء على لسان
المسؤولين
الاثيوبيين او على او في الاعلام الاثيوبي
او كما تكرم ضيفكم الكريم من اديس ابا
الان ان مفيش ضرر طيب طالما وان اثيوبيا
بتسعه لمصلحه اثيوبيا ومصلحه السودان
ومصلحه مصر احنا احنا يعني لا نشكد في هذا
طب لماذا لا نترجم ذلك الى الى الى الى
الى الى مذكره تفاهم لماذا لا نترجم هذه
النوايا المتبادله بين مصر والسودان
واثيوبيا
نضعها حضرتك حضرتك حتى في لا ورقه
بحيث
اثيوبيا ونحن يعني لا نشكل في روايات
تطمئن السودان او تطمئن مصر ان يعني انا
هركز حديثي على مصر تطمئن مصر انها في
المستقبل
عندما يحتمل الملك عندما يكتمل ملء سد
النهضه انه الحكومه الاثيوبيه والحكومات
الاثيوبيه في المستقبل والحكومات
الاثيوبيه في المستقبل هتعمل في نفس
السياق اللي بتعمل فيه الحكومه الاثيوبيه
الحاليه هو عدم تشغيل سد النهضه لان يقع
باي ضرر على مصر ازاي اترجم حضرتك يقع باي
ضرر على مصر ان كميتها في المياه اللي
خمسه وخمسين مليار متر مكعب سنويا لا
تتاثر جمله مهمه من النقاط ذكرتها سيد
حسين
اريد ان اسال سيد كامل شمسه
بهذه المقاربه يعني بهذه اللغه التصالحيه
من قبل الطرف المصري لماذا يعني لم تلقى
اذان صغير لدى الطرف الاثيوبي حتى الان هل
التجاهل تجاهل قلق دول معنيه بهذا الملف
وهو حيوي وامن قومي لها هو امر يعني سيقود
الى حاله سلام بين الاطراف
اثيوبيا يعني تصغي لهذا الموضوع كما يعرف
الجميع اثيوبيا لها تاريخ انها تهتم
بالقبل ليس بقضيتها الوطنيه الداخليه فقط
تهتم بالقضايا الافريقيه كلها يهمها شؤونه
اخواني الافارقه يعني
مصر والسودان قضيتهم قضيتنا شعبهم شعبنا
نحن لا نريد تعطيش الشعب المصري تعطيش او
نقص اي قطر من المياه التي تصلهم لكن ما
تعرضه اثيوبيا انه يعني الاستخدام
والاحادي او الاستحواذ او ان اذا يعني
التمسك بالقضايا التاريخيه
يعني ميثاقيات التي الجائره القديمه الان
اذا كانت
نيه سيد سامي شكري يعني دفع الحوار الى
الامام والرجوع الى المفاوضه والجزوس حول
الطاوله نحن ايضا نرحب بها واثيوبيا تريد
ان تعبر
يعني ان تطبق ما تعبره باقوالها الى
الافعال نحن دائما مع الحوار مع المفاوضه
لكن ما هي الاطراف التي يعني تنبغي ينبغي
ان ان تقوم كوسيط واين وكيف وهذه الامور
دائما مصر هي التي تقول يمين يسار نحن
دائما قضيتنا واضحه نريد ان يعني استخدام
هذا المياه ونريد ان يستخدمها اشقاؤنا ولا
نريد ان نلحق الضرر ونعرف هذه كلها الان
الذي هل الذي يضع شروطات من الذي يريد نعم
من الذي يضع الشروط يعني القاسيه التي
يعني تعرقل هذا المسار يعني هذا شيء معروف
اصلا ليست اثيوبيا اثيوبيا كل دائما ترحب
بالحوار وبالمفاوضه في كل
المستويات صيد حسين في حديث الوساطه كان
هناك السيد سامح شكري حديث عن تعويل مصري
على حاله من الضغط العربي على الطرف
الاثيوبي من اجل الذهاب
لعمليه تفاوض تفضي الى اتفاق ما هو التصور
المصري لنوع الضغط الذي يمكن ان يمارس
عربيا ربما من اجل ترغيب اثيوبيا بهذا
المسار
يعني انا حضرتك
المقاربه بتاعتي مقاربه دبلوماسيه افريقيه
عربيه
لموضوع سد النهضه
ولذلك
الموضوع بالنسبه لي حضرتك وفي اطار هذه
المقاربه ليس ضغطا وليس تهديدا
وانما هو
يعني بنوظف العلاقات العربيه الاثيوبيه
والعلاقات الافريقيه الاثيوبيه والعلاقات
المصريه الافريقيه ونحن اثيوبيا ننتمي الى
القاره السوداء ونحن اثيوبيا من الدول
المؤسسه المؤسسه لمنظمه الوحده الافريقيه
سابقا والاتحاد الافريقي حاليا ونعمل
ونتعاون فيما بيننا ومع سائر الدول
الاعضاء في الاتحاد الافريقي من اجل اعلاء
اعلاء كل ما
العمل الافريقي المشترك وسد النهضه ده
موضوع يهم نحن نحن اول طرف مصر اول طرف
يدرك ان موضوع سد النهضه ده موضوع افريقي
ونتفق مع الطرح في مجلس الامن الدولي انه
يجب ان يحلف الاطار الافريقي
لان افريقيا بالنسبه لنا دوت النيل بينبع
النيل بينبع من افريقيا في افريقيا
بالنسبه لمصر دوت حضرتك مصدر الحياه في
مصر وبالتالي يعني انا هحط نفسي مكان يعني
اسمحي لي بس كده تعليقا على المداخله
السابقه الكريم انا هحط نفسي مكانهم
يعني انا هحط نفسي
طيب
انا انا بقى طيب انا اتقدم بمقترح يعني
انا في مصر بتقول احنا عايزين
مشروع نتفاوض على مشروع طيب انتوا اطرحوا
النظر يعني اثيوبيا دائما كل ما مصر تطالب
بهذا
بترفض طيب بدل الرفض بدل الرفض وانتم ولا
شكه لدينا ان انتم مصلحتكم حوار معنا طيب
بدل الرفض تقدموا انتم بمشروع نستطيع هذا
سنقله للسيد كامل سيد كامل لماذا لا تطرح
اثيوبيا مثل هذه المقاربه حول امكانيه
التفاوض اوراق يمكن التفاوض عليها وفي اي
مساحات يمكن ان تطرحها يعني كانت هناك
مساحات دوليه وايضا المساحه الافريقيه
التي تنادي بها اثيوبيا
اختي الكريمه قبل اقحام الدول العربيه في
هذا الموضوع يعني هناك سلسله يعني او سلك
دبلوماسي وعلاقه الخارجيه وزاره الخارجيه
وزاره المياه وزاره الري والمياه موجوده
في اثيوبيا ويوناكو وزاره يعني مماثله لها
في مصر هناك دبلوماسيه موجوده بين
الدولتين ما يحتاج انها تقرا هذه القضيه
في غير مكانها لازم انها يعني تتقدم يعني
اسئلتها وجندتها
ومقترحاتها الى اثيوبيا او الى الدو الى
الوسيط كما تقدمها يعني بضيفك الكريم ضيفك
الكريم الى مجلس الامن او الى لا هذه كلها
ينبغي انها تطرح هذه الاجنده في البيت
الافريقي يعني وتضع برنامج لها متى نبدا
في الحوار ومتى نعود الى المفاوضه وما هي
يعني المعوقات التي يعني اوقفت هذه
السابقا هل هي من الطرف الاثيوبي من
النصري نحن دائما يعني نيتنا صالحه وكما
نقول دائما في كل المستويات الان يعني
لماذا طرحت وتقدمت باشياء كثيره ولكن يعني
المصريين والسودانيين يعني مره يتخطون الى
الامام ومره يتخطون الى القلب يعني يخطون
خطوه الى الخلف هذا هي المماطله ليست من
اثيوبيا اثيوبيا نعم هي تستمر في بنايه سد
النهضه وهي ايضا تملا الملا الرابع في
وقته ليس الان لكن قبل ذلك الان امامنا
وقت طويل امامنا فرصه لكي نعود للمفاوضه
لكي نعود للحوار ولكي نثير هذه القضيه في
مكاني في وقت في في الوضعيه المناسبه يعني
نحن لا لم نرفض ما يعني
ليس لنا اي سيره او اي في اي وقت نحن
رفضنا الطرح المصري لكن نحن نرفض الفرض
نفرض الاجبار نفرض نرفض التدخل الخارجي
والخطوط الطويله التي يعني تاخذ مثلا
المسار الى نيويورك الى لا خلوه تعالوا
الى الديس ابا تعالوا الى الجامعه
الافريقيه للاتحاد الافريقي يجلسوا نجلس
الاعني المعنيين يجلسوا مع بعض يناقشوا في
الموضوع هناك ليس انا اقول لك هناك طريقه
هناك يعني علاقه دبلوماسيه في وزاره
الخارجيه وزاره الرياء وفي هناك سفراء
سفير المصري بوجودنا وسفير اثيوبي موجودنا
في يعني على ابواب كلها مفتوحه يعني
شكرا لك من اديس ابابا كامل شمس عضو
البرلمان الاثيوبيه ومن القاهره سفير حسين
هريدي مساعد وزير الخارجيه المصريه الاسبق
شكرا لكما والى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر دمتم بخير والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]